[Musica]
che peccato
queste sono le parole che mi sono
sentito recapitare più spesso da chi mi
stava intorno quando comunicai di
lasciare degli studi canonici per
avvicinarmi al mondo del cinema che
peccato peccato
peccato come quello originale per molti
la cosa strana è che molti me lo
dicevano dei loro lettini estivi
discutendo se il finale di harry potter
fosse realmente quello giusto con lo
sfondo di di carlo sullo smartphone e
con la rivista aperta sulla pagina del
cinema
una prima grande ombra che mi hanno
lasciato addosso forse l'unica che non
capirò mai nonostante gli sforzi
e qui per me si apre un mondo un grande
interrogativo
secondo voi come viene vista l'arte
ve lo chiedo perché oggi io finalmente
riesco a venire qua davanti a un
pubblico e dire con estrema tranquillità
quello che faccio che cosa mi occupo al
lavoro sicuramente strano non tanto è
per il suo essere il regista bene o male
tutti sanno quello che fa un regista con
un pizzico di esperienza direi che forse
però più che altro tutti sanno quello
che non fa si sa che non ripara le
tubature che non cucina per nessuno che
non si reca la mattina alle 8 verso la
zona industriale a timbrare il
cartellino
però in realtà se ci pensiamo bene
probabilmente nessuno sa realmente
quello che fa e non sapere le cose ci
spaventa a morte
la paura è sempre in quello che non si
sa la paura del buio no per esempio non
è la paura di qualcosa di tangibile
all'opposto della paura di qualcosa che
non vediamo perciò non vedendo ci
potrebbe essere di tutto
non sappiamo cosa c'è nel buio non
sappiamo cosa c'è nel cinema come si fa
e chi lo fa abbiamo paura del diverso di
chi fa cose diverse dalle nostre questo
è risaputo ed ecco nessuno in realtà sa
niente di cosa fa un regista di cosa fa
un attore o un direttore della
fotografia
non c'è a bordo sette il pensionato con
le mani dietro la schiena no che scuote
la testa perché uno sceglie lo slider
per un inquadratura e lui dice è una
volta avrebbero usato il crane non c'è
perché nessuno sa nulla voi sapete come
funziona un 7 per esempio quali sono le
metodologie per fare un prodotto
cinematografico
vi faccio un esempio in un film in media
in un giorno si girano 34 minuti di roba
buona quando ho girato uno dei miei
primi cortometraggi venne mio babbo a
trovarmi sul set piacevole e mi disse
accidenti o mandate lenti
ecco in quel corto abbiamo girato 7
minuti al giorno
strano no e se andate al doppio della
velocità normale sentirsi dire che siamo
lenti ha d'altronde cosa poteva saperne
lui abituato a ritmi di un altro lavoro
sapeva però lui e mia mamma che il
figlio era finalmente contento e questo
faceva essere contenti anche loro e
forse è stato l'aiuto più grande
comunque però ecco la difficoltà
maggiore per una scelta artistica
genere il regista per di più è la
mancanza totale di un percorso da
seguire 0 calcare nella sua serie parla
dei famosi bordi da strappare no sono
belli perché si sa già cosa si deve fare
qui invece voi immaginate un punto di
partenza un punto di arrivo e un
infinità di sentieri di luce un infinita
che porta d'arrivo non è infinita hanno
lavorato d'altronde si sa è
difficilissimo precede uno studio matto
e disperatissimo e dispendioso proprio
fisicamente
l'unica certezza è la strada impervia ma
quella è
ti devi laurea in giurisprudenza ed ecco
e da qui non si scappa quindi un pezzo
di vita e segnato no c'è il bordeaux da
strappare poi fatto che lo va preso
l'abilitazione di avvocato ed è quel
test maledettamente difficile però
volente o nolente devi superare quello
puoi farcela poi non farcela ma la
strada è quella
qui invece c'è di tutto allora dici che
fai ti guardi le biografie no dice quale
percorso ha fatto fellini e vedi una
strada quale percorso ha fatto
sorrentino e vede un'altra strada quale
percorso ha fatto garrone ancora
un'altra poi credi di aver trovato una
sicurezza e conosci uno che ha fatto la
strada di sorrentino ma oggi fa il
pizzaiolo 1 quella di fellini e oggi e
assicuratore se per che cosa pazzesca è
che quella stessa strada può essere
agevole per uno ma completamente
impervia per un altro e questo accade in
tutta l'arte indistintamente
e io in tutto questo per ora sarei un
passo indietro al talento cioè quello
viene dovuta professionisti come tutti i
mestieri no anche qualche commerciali
stava amministra le multinazionali e
qualcuno fra le dichiarazioni dei
redditi per i pensionati di paese e mi
scuseranno i commercialisti se le ho
prese ad esempio ecco qui noi siamo un
passo indietro quando magari il talento
ci sarebbe anche ma ma non viene
perseguito
ovviamente è più facile quando sei
figlio di un artista ma non per le
raccomandazioni non c'entra niente
lasciamole perdere è più facile perché
vive in un ambiente in cui l'arte è di
casa i tuoi genitori avranno amici e
colleghi di quel mondo vederla serali
dando da mangiare quindi immagini che
per primo che qualcosa guadagnino e non
solo se anche fuori no si rende conto
che in realtà lavorare in questi settori
ha un suo senso una sua logica io invece
vengo da all'esatto opposto ma non
perché i genitori non volessero facesse
questo è vero ho detto anzi me l'hanno
pagata loro la scuola non economica che
ho fatto sono uno di quelli è potuto
partire con degli strumenti per provarci
ma era la mia situazione di background
sociale ad essere tanto tossica e se
posso direi soprattutto
ipocrita
perché una situazione che costruiva un
modello disfunzionale no del rapporto
con l'arte
c'era un background ha fatto di lavori
classici canonici in cui non c'è
assolutamente niente di male che però a
loro volta vede nei figli dei lavori
classici e canonici lo stesso background
però si atteggia grazie all'arte sono
quelli che fanno gli abbonamenti annuali
a teatro vanno si annoiano ci si
addormentano solo per dire il giorno
dopo quando vanno a giocare a tennis
ieri sono stato a teatro a vedere questa
straordinaria commedia di pirandello
come se l'arte in o forse qualcosa per
rilevare il loro status gli stessi però
quando si incontrano ti dicono peccato e
lo dicono a te ai suoi genitori
forse non dai loro l'opportunità di
elevarsi ho cominciato a vederla così o
almeno non gliela dai per ora
negli anni però diventa professionista e
proprio perché professionista mi sono
reso conto che probabilmente è proprio
l'arte stessa ad essere qualcosa di
veramente paradossale qua da noi e
quindi torniamo all'inizio no andiamo al
concreto come viene vista l'arte il
primo significato secondo me sta
nell'importanza che prende
dall'istruzione il cinema per esempio
non prevede un percorso universitario
classe sono scuole private e
costosissime
stessa cosa per il teatro per la danza
per la moda per le nuove forme grafiche
fotografie fanno parte solo di accademie
private e nei giovani è difficilissimo
prendere la scelta di studiare questo
tipo di materie anche perché per molti
si deve chiedere un enorme sforzo
economico ai genitori che non prevede
fasce isee senza alla fine dare la
certezza di un lavoro di uno stipendio
alla fine di questo percorso
allo stesso tempo invece esistono
università pubblica e riconosciuta per i
futuri critici di danza teatro cinema
fotografia costume mi verrebbe da dire
un piccolo ritratto italiano non
professionisti nel dire agli altri cosa
va e non va bene ma senza sapere neanche
in che modo questi altri poi facciano
realmente le cose e poi è chiaro che si
afferma un altro concetto un concetto
che io ho sempre combattuto con forza ma
in cui e poi ti ritrovi a farne parte
anche il problema sociale
l'arte come strumento in mano a un'elite
le scuole private costosissime fanno già
la prima grande selezione naturale
sbagliata cioè non in base alle capacità
all'innovazione delle idee 20 ma in base
a che può permettersi di pagare queste
rate con molti zeri e poi di conseguenza
scoraggia ad investire in queste scuole
per i loro figli anche quelli che
potrebbero permettersi di farlo ma come
dicevamo prima loro non vedono futuro in
un settore dell'arte no perché per loro
è sconosciuto e da fuori sembra più un
gioco magari è un mestiere
non avete idea di quanto ero imbarazzato
all'inizio della mia carriera quando mi
trovavo a dare ordini a stagisti con 15
20 anni più di me era paradossale
ricordo una ragazza di 35 anni
torno ancora una volta lì commercialista
perché era il futuro ai genitori
vedevano per lei e di conseguenza
l'unico che gli avevano finanziato e lei
da sola ha lavorato per qualche anno per
permettersi di fare quello che aveva
sempre voluto cioè il cinema e
nonostante la grande differenza d'età
ascoltava con una bambina delle
elementari ascolta al maestro lei voleva
entrare in questo mondo a tutti i costi
era determinata a ripartire da zero
contro tutto e tutti sapendo che era
tardi ma fregandosene ho avuto una volta
uno stagista di 47 anni la vita lo ha
portato a fare tutt'altro e non poteva
permettersi a suo tempo di studiare
cinema in nessun modo famiglia mancavano
le economie si è rimesso sotto da grande
non perché ne volesse fare il lavoro
della vita come la ragazza ma perché non
voleva rinunciare a provare a stare
dentro a quel mondo che tanto avrebbe
voluto da giovane e lui era sul set
stavano un angolo un soldatino per una
sera fine stage
parlando davanti a una birra mi raccontò
che era un ingegnere elettronico a capo
di un reparto molto importante in una
grande azienda che conoscevo anche
insomma lui era un eccellenza
prendeva i giorni di ferie per venire
sui nostri sette ad imparare io rimasi
basito
magari sarebbe stato un grande talento
anche nel cinema chissà ma ormai era
troppo tardi era vecchio lou reed in
qualche modo si accontentava di farne
parte di essere lì a vivere quasi un
sogno si potrebbe dire come sarebbe
bello non pensavo farlo parlare cinque
minuti con quelli che dicevano
peccato
però poi da professionista sei costretto
a vedere anche altro perché arriva il
tuo turno devi far vedere quello che sa
fare devi tirare fuori le cose da dentro
di te
e qui quando sembra di aver fatto la
cosa più importante
arrivano le vere difficoltà
c'è quella del foglio bianco per esempio
ha una quantità di idee geniali e meno
geniali che passano per la testa senza
sapere come metterle giu
il concetto di grande portata che però
non si adatta alla storia
l'attesa sì perché l'attesa in questo
mondo è la cosa peggiore per molti è
difficile aspettare cinque minuti alla
sano altri rinunciano alla pesca perché
non tollerano due ore di attesa per
vedere la anna muoversi qui non è poi
raro dover attendere anni per un
progetto e l'attesa ancora una volta
mette a dura prova soprattutto il
giovane esordiente perché anche se
consapevole di capacità e sensibilità
particolari e difficile dimostrarle se
non ci sono progetti da far vedere e
allora si riapre tutto il circolo di
prima
come farò ad affermarmi come farò a
dimostrare a chi ha creduto in me ed
investito in me che ha fatto bene
affidarsi e soprattutto come farò a
dimostrare a tutti quelli che dicevano
peccato che loro per me sono stati solo
una spinta ad uscirne vivo
prendiamo un video
vedi
devi essere così
deciso ma dolce
importante dolce vita così dolce
secondo che ti piacciono proprio morti
per te piacciono i vivi
abbastanza
beppe comunque sta via meglio quei baffi
perché lei tagliati
ma secondo te ti sta ascoltando
sono i riti che non ascoltano
ma lo sai che vedo perché spesso uno
nella vita parla parla parla
io li preparo per il loro ultimo viaggio
voglio vi siano perfetti
mettiti nei suoi panni non vorresti
essere preparato bene
sinceramente non ci ho mai pensato
ecco stavolta ci hai pensato
e così di ombre si riempì anche racconto
di un giovane autore di un giovane
regista
sì perché per una generazione che è
cresciuta dentro la più grande crisi
economica dal dopoguerra che quando
doveva spiccare il volo si è trovata di
fronte alla pandemia di comite e che ora
vive pure i venti di guerra in europa è
difficile non vedere le ombre
siamo la prima generazione che non
crescerà rispetto a quella dei propri
padri e così tante volte i giovani
autori e contestava me per primo un
eccessiva crudezza un violento realismo
io ho un tema e mi lega in tutte le
storie che proprio l'ombra della vita la
morte
io dal dramma alla commedia alla battuta
più leggera a quella più alta è per me è
inevitabile finire lì in qualche modo il
mio ultimo film è incentrato proprio su
colui che accompagnava il momento tra
vita e morte
il necroforo che veste trucca le salme
per l'ultima esposizione
prima di vederlo prima tanti hanno usato
questi termini sul mio lavoro
horror gotico
inquietante
dopo la visione è mutato tutto poetico
dolce
consapevole com'è possibile mi chiedevo
perché la prima impressione è stata
quella certo io non ho neanche mai
pensato ai primi tre aggettivi quando
scrivevo il film per me era sempre la
poesia al centro la consapevolezza ma
normalmente se si parla di morte si è
feticisti gotici orribili io di questa
cosa però ne vado fiero non come
francesco rossi e ma come generazione
sì perché penso che noi vicini ai 30
anni
siamo più consapevoli della morte come
di tante cose brutte del mondo brutte ma
inevitabile e quindi la nostra
operazione non è più quella di scansarle
ma è quella di dare loro un nuovo valore
d ombra ecco partendo dal fatto di
considerarle e quindi la morte per
esempio torna al centro della narrazione
perché in realtà stiamo parlando della
vita quando parliamo della morte
siamo consapevoli e la consapevolezza ci
permette di apprezzare ancora di più
quello che abbiamo siamo in grado di
vedere tutte le sue accezioni quindi di
uscire dal presupposto di cosa significa
una cosa per noi vedere il suo
significato
altrove che ne so in ghana per esempio
la morte viene danzata perché il per
loro è la ricongiunzione con gli
antenati in india viene vista come parte
di quel ciclo di reincarnazione perpetua
e quando noi le scriviamo le nostre cose
andiamo a cogliere i dettagli di questa
bellezza andiamo a cercarla in ogni
gesto perché abbiamo bisogno di bellezza
ecco ora noi abbiamo parlato di ombre e
di luci come
sovrastrutture di quello che ci lasciano
nel cinema però le ombre hanno un
significato diverso che che è molto
tecnico no sono all'interno di
un'immagine quelle parti rimangono sotto
esposte quelle tendenti al nero per
capirci il suo opposto non sono le luci
ma le alte luci cioè quelle parti
sovraesposte che tendono sempre di più
al bianco le luci fanno parte della
normalità perché senza la luce non ci
sarebbe il cinema no non ci sarebbe
niente da scrivere sulla pellicola però
se usiamo queste luci in maniera
omogenea il risultato non è dei migliori
l'immagine ci risulta molto piatta si
dice in gergo flat non ci entusiasma non
cerea paure le gioie
semplicemente ci stucca quindi abbiamo
bisogno delle ombre è una necessità per
creare contrasto per tirare fuori
qualcosa e quindi forse ho capito che
pure io avevo bisogno di essere trattato
come l'immagine cinematografica che
forse tutti quelli che vogliono in
qualche modo avere a che fare con l'arte
ne hanno bisogno
siamo uguali a quelle immagini che
vediamo dentro le sale e allora se
qualcuno mi chiede perché mi porto
dietro le ombre a cosa servono queste
ombre
io gli dico che è proprio grazie a loro
che riesco a vedere quanto sono belle le
luci grazie
[Musica]